Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
de l’inflation. Alors non, pas l’inflation
monétaire, même si c’est une question
importante, mais l’inflation cosmique. L’inflation
cosmique c’est un phénomène étonnant
qui aurait eu lieu dans les tous premiers
instants du Big-Bang, et qui expliquerait
certaines des caractéristiques étonnantes
de notre Univers.
L’inflation, c’est le fait que pendant
un temps incroyablement court, 10-33 secondes,
l’Univers aurait vu sa taille augmenter
d’un facteur 10 puissance 27. Ça veut dire
qu’il serait devenu 1 milliards de milliards
de milliards de fois plus gros, en 1 millionième
de milliardième de milliardième de milliardième
de secondes.
Ca donne le vertige, non ? Alors voyons ensemble
comment et pourquoi l’inflation cosmique
se serait produite.
[jingle]
Le meilleur modèle dont on dispose aujourd’hui
pour expliquer l’histoire et l’évolution
de l’Univers, c’est le modèle du Big-Bang.
Et contrairement à ce qu’on entend parfois,
ce modèle n’est pas juste une théorie,
il a de nombreuses confirmations expérimentales
très solides.
[PREUVES On peut citer notamment le décalage
vers le rouge des galaxies, qui témoigne
de l’expansion de l’Univers. Ou encore
le rayonnement fossile, qui est une sorte
de photo de l’état de l’Univers, tel
qu’il était 300 000 ans après le BigBang.]
J’ai déjà parlé de ces différents sujets
dans des vidéos précédentes, et j’ai
toujours insisté : le modèle du Big-Bang
est très très bien corroboré par ces observations.
Et pourtant, dans sa version initiale, ce
modèle a quand même quelques petits problèmes.
Et c’est pour régler ces problèmes que
dans les années 70 et 80, des physiciens
comme Alexei Starobinski, Alan Guth et Andrei
Linde, ont proposé d’y ajouter un ingrédient
: le concept de d’inflation cosmique. Mais
avant de plonger là-dedans, revoyons d’abord
les bases de ce qui constitue le modèle du
Big-Bang.
[EVOLUTION Si on devait raconter l’histoire
de l’Univers avec une seule courbe, ce serait
celle-ci. Alors attendez pas de panique, je
vais réexpliquer tranquillement ce que ça
veut dire.
Sur l’axe horizontal, vous avez le temps,
exprimé en milliards d’années. Le temps
présent, c’est ici, par convention on le
note t=0. Avant c’est le passé, et après
c’est l’avenir.
Vous le savez le modèle du Big-Bang nous
dit que l’Univers est en expansion, qu’il
grossit donc, et que dans le passé au contraire
il était plus contracté sur lui-même. Donc
on pourrait être tentés de penser que cette
courbe que je vous trace ici représente simplement
l’évolution de la taille de l’Univers
en fonction du temps.
Mais non, ça n’est pas tout à fait ça.
On ne connait pas la taille de l’Univers,
et ça se trouve il est même infini. Cette
quantité n’est pas exactement la taille,
mais ce qu’on appelle le facteur d’échelle.
Le facteur d’échelle, on peut dire en gros
que c’est la taille de l’Univers à un
instant t, mais par rapport à sa taille actuelle.
Regardez ici au moment présent, à t=0, le
facteur d’échelle vaut 1. Aujourd’hui
l’Univers a la taille qu’il a. Dans le
futur ce facteur augmente, car l’Univers
va s’étendre. Et dans le passé le facteur
est plus petit que 1.
Par exemple on voit qu’il y a 8 milliards
d’années, il valait 0.5, ce qui signifie
que l’Univers était si on veut deux fois
plus petit qu’aujourd’hui.]
Mais qu’est-ce que ça veut dire deux fois
plus petit, puisqu’on a dit qu’on ne sait
même pas si l’Univers est fini ou infini
? Eh bien il ne faut pas l’interpréter
comme une taille, mais comme l’évolution
des distances dans l’Univers, par exemple
entre les différentes galaxies.
[FACTEUR Imaginons une galaxie qui serait
située aujourd’hui à 2 milliards d’années-lumières
de nous. Il y a 8 milliards d’années, puisque
le facteur d’échelle était de 0.5, ça
veut dire qu’elle n’était qu’à la
moitié, c’est à dire 1 milliards d’années
lumières de nous.
Inversement dans disons 6 milliards d’années,
le facteur d’échelle sera 1.5, donc la
galaxie sera à 3 milliards d’années de
nous. La courbe d’évolution du facteur
d’échelle permet donc de reconstituer l’histoire
de l’expansion de l’Univers en quantifiant
la dilatation des distances.
Et ce que l’on voit d’étonnant sur cette
courbe, c’est que le facteur d’échelle
diminue quand on remonte dans le passé, et
semblait valoir zéro il y a 13.8 milliards
d’années environ. Et c’est cette période
qu’on appelle le Big-Bang.
Alors attention, comme je le dis souvent,
on ne peut pas vraiment parler d’instant
zéro. On peut juste dire qu’il y a 13.8
milliards d’années l’Univers était dans
un état extrêmement contracté, et donc
très dense et très chaud. Et ce sont d’ailleurs
les conséquences de cet état qu’on peut
observer aujourd’hui par exemple avec le
rayonnement fossile.]
Pour comprendre ce qu’il s’est vraiment
passé vraiment dans les tous premiers instants,
il faudrait combiner la cosmologie et la théorie
quantique, et ça, j’ai eu l’occasion
d’en parler plusieurs fois, c’est compliqué,
donc on ne peut pas en dire grand chose aujourd’hui.
[HUBBLE Bien, excepté la questions des tous
premiers instants, la courbe du facteur d’échelle
nous permet donc de reconstituer notamment
l’évolution de la distance entre les galaxies.
Mais elle nous donne également une autre
info très importante : le rythme auquel les
galaxies s’éloignent les unes des autres.
Eh oui ce rythme d’éloignement à un instant
t, c’est tout simplement la pente de la
courbe. Ici par exemple, à l’instant présent,
on voit que le facteur d’échelle est en
train d’augmenter, ce qui signifie que les
galaxies s’éloignent les unes des autres.
Et la pente de la courbe permet de savoir
à quelle vitesse cela se produit pour deux
galaxies données.
La valeur numérique de cette pente, c’est
la fameuse constante de Hubble, qu’on note
généralement H0. La vitesse d’éloignement
sera d’autant plus grande que les galaxies
sont lointaines, et H0 c’est le facteur
de proportionnalité.
Si on regarde l’évolution de la pente de
la courbe au cours du temps, on voit que dans
le passé, notamment proche du Big-Bang, elle
était plus raide, donc le rythme de l’expansion
était plus élevé qu’aujourd’hui.
Et dans le futur également elle va finir
par se raidir à nouveau, de plus en plus
d’ailleurs. Et ça c’est à cause de l’expansion
accélérée de l’Univers, qu’on attribue
aujourd’hui à ce qu’on appelle l’énergie
noire ou l’énergie sombre.]
Alors très bien, je suis en train de vous
décrire le passé et le destin de l’Univers
à partir de ma courbe d’évolution du facteur
d’échelle, mais je ne vous ai même pas
expliqué d’où elle sort cette courbe ! Comment
on la trace, d’où vient sa forme ?
Eh bien c’est une application de la théorie
de la relativité générale au cas de l’Univers
tout entier. En Relativité générale, il
y a une équation centrale, c’est l’équation
d’Einstein.
[EQ EINSTEIN Cette équation un peu obscure
nous dit en gros que la courbure de l’espace-temps
dépend de son contenu en matière et en énergie.
L’équation d’Einstein est très compliquée
à résoudre en général, mais en l’appliquant
au cas de l’Univers entier, avec quelques
hypothèses simplificatrices, on tombe sur
une équation beaucoup plus simple, qui décrit
justement l’évolution du facteur d’échelle
au cours du temps.
En résolvant cette équation, on peut tracer
la courbe associée. Il y a quand même quelques
paramètres dans l’équation, comme la constante
de Hubble H0, c’est-à-dire la pente actuelle
de la courbe. Et il faut aussi connaitre la
densité actuelle d’énergie contenue dans
l’Univers, soit sous la forme de matière
ordinaire ou de matière noire, soit sous
la forme d’énergie sombre.]
Mais une fois qu’on connait les valeurs
pour ces différents paramètres, on peut
tracer la courbe que je vous ai montré, et
comme je vous l’ai dit, tout ça marche
hyper bien. On a de nombreuses confirmations
expérimentales de ce scénario, et des estimations
assez précises des paramètres, tout ça
grâce à plusieurs observations astrophysiques
indépendantes.
Mais il y a tout de même un petit problème
avec le modèle du Big Bang tel que je vous
l’ai présenté : c’est la question de
la forme globale de l’Univers. On l’a
dit, l’équation d’Einstein fait intervenir
la courbure de l’espace-temps, et dans la
courbure de l’espace-temps, il y a en particulier
la courbure de l’espace, tout court, qui
détermine la forme globale de l’Univers.
[COURBURE Et il y a 3 cas possibles : soit
l’espace a globalement une courbure positive,
on parle d’Univers sphérique et fermé.
Dans ce cas là l’Univers serait de taille
finie.
Soit la courbure spatiale est négative, on
parle d’univers hyperbolique et ouvert.
On pourrait voire plutôt sa forme comme celle
d’une sorte de Pringles infini.
Et enfin dernière possibilité, juste entre
les deux. Si la courbure spatiale est globalement
nulle, on dit que l’Univers est plat, et
dans ce cas il serait également infini.
Notez que je vous mets des petits dessins
qui représentent ces 3 cas pour des surfaces
en 2 dimensions, mais c’est purement illustratif,
puisque notre Univers a 3 dimensions d’espace,
donc c’est difficile à représenter.]
Bien maintenant comment on fait pour identifier
dans lequel des 3 cas on se trouve, nous,
dans l’Univers qui est le nôtre ? Est-ce
qu’on vit dans un Univers sphérique et
donc de taille finie, ou hyperbolique et infinie
? C’est important comme question, non ? Eh
bien pour le savoir, il faut regarder les
paramètres de l’équation d’Einstein.
[COURBURE Je l’ai évoqué, l’équation
d’Einstein nous dit en gros : courbure d’espace-temps
égale contenu en matière et énergie. Or
dans notre cas simple, la courbure d’espace-temps
peut être décomposée en une partie qui
représente la courbure temporelle, et une
autre la courbure spatiale.
La courbure temporelle ça peut paraitre bizarre
comme notion, mais elle est liée à la constante
de Hubble. Je schématise beaucoup, mais la
constante de Hubble représente la vitesse
d’expansion de l’Univers, et on peut interpréter
cela comme une courbure temporelle.
Donc vous voyez que si on connait la quantité
de matière et d’énergie actuellement présente,
et qu’on connait la valeur de la constante
de Hubble, on peut par soustraction en déduire
la partie qui nous manque, la courbure spatiale,
et donc connaitre la forme de l’Univers.
Et il y a 3 cas possibles. S’il y a beaucoup
de matière-énergie par rapport à la valeur
de H0, la courbure spatiale sera positive,
et l’Univers sera donc sphérique et de
taille finie. Si on contraire il y a trop
peu de matière et d’énergie par rapport
à H0, la courbure sera négative, Univers
hyperbolique de taille infinie.
Et enfin si la densité de matière-énergie
est pile égale à la bonne valeur par rapport
à H0, la courbure sera nulle, et on sera
dans un Univers plat.
Vous voyez que pour savoir dans quelle situation
on se trouve, tout dépend de la quantité
de matière et d’énergie par rapport à
la constante de Hubble. Il y a un seuil critique
de densité : si on est au-dessus, c’est
sphérique, en-dessous hyperbolique, et pile
à la valeur critique : Univers plat.
On peut calculer ce seuil critique à partir
de H0, et la valeur numérique correspond
environ à 5 protons par m3. C’est ça la
frontière, entre les cas sphérique et hyperbolique.
La question c’est donc de savoir si nous,
dans notre Univers, on est au-dessus ou en-dessous
de cette valeur de densité.]
Pour le savoir on ne va pas aller compter
les protons dans l’espace intersidéral,
les valeurs de densité de matière et d’énergie
peuvent être estimées par observations astrophysiques
comme les mesures du rayonnement cosmologique.
[DECOMPTE Je vous ai mis le décompte ici
des densités d’énergie, l’unité c’est
le Joule par m3. Pour faire plus simple, on
a pris l’habitude de les exprimer en fraction
de la densité critique. La matière ordinaire,
ça fait environ un vingtième de la densité
critique, donc sa valeur c’est 0.05 fois
la densité critique. La matière noire, environ
il y en a environ 0.27. Et l’énergie noire,
représente environ 0.68 fois la densité
critique.
Donc question, est-ce qu’au total on est
au-dessus ou en-dessous de la densité critique
? Eh bien voyons…donc si on fait le total
des 3 composantes…ah ben c’est fou, quand
on ajoute les trois on a pile la valeur de
la densité critique. Quel coup de bol !
Alors ok, nos estimations sont précises à
environ 1%, ça veut dire qu’on peut considérer
que la quantité totale de matière et d’énergie
présente dans l’Univers est comprise entre
allez 0.99 et 1.01 fois la densité critique.
Donc on ne sait pas si on est au-dessus ou
en-dessous !]
C’est bizarre quand même, non. Se dire
que dans l’Univers, il y a pile la quantité
d’énergie nécessaire pour qu’on soit
dans un espace plat ? On pourrait l’accepter
simplement et dire qu’on est tombé dans
un Univers qui avait cette valeur pile à
1% près. Mais ce genre d’argument, invoquer
un coup de bol, en sciences on n’aime pas
trop quand même.
Et je vous passe les détails mais la situation
est encore pire si on regarde dans le passé.
Pour qu’on ait ça aujourd’hui, la bonne
valeur à 1% près, il aurait fallu qu’aux
premiers instants du Big-Bang la quantité
de matière et d’énergie soit réglée
à un facteur 10-64 près pour s’assurer
qu’on ait cette valeur aujourd’hui.
Ce que cet argument nous dit, c’est qu’en
principe, il n’aurait dû y avoir aucune
chance pour que l’Univers soit si plat aujourd’hui.
Et pourtant il l’est. Et c’est donc cela
le premier problème du modèle du Big-Bang
: pourquoi l’Univers est-il si plat alors
qu’il ne devrait pas ?
En soit c’est déjà embêtant, mais on
va voir maintenant un autre problème qui
semble du même genre : pourquoi l’Univers
est-il si homogène ?
[jingle]
Une chose importante qu’on constate quand
on fait des observations astrophysiques, c’est
que que les choses ont l’air d’être globalement
identiques quelle que soit la région de l’Univers
qu’on regarde.
Les galaxies ont l’air du même genre, agencées
de la même façon, et il y a en la même
quantité approximativement. Et donc à grande
échelle en tout cas, l’Univers semble tout
à fait homogène. Et c’est même encore
plus flagrant avec le rayonnement fossile.
Le rayonnement fossile, on en a parlé, c’est
un rayonnement électromagnétique émis environ
300 000 ans après le Big Bang. Et ce rayonnement
baigne aujourd’hui l’ensemble de l’Univers.
Ils nous arrive donc de tous les côtés,
et quelle que soit la direction qu’on regarde,
ce rayonnement semble toujours presque exactement
le même.
[CMB Ce qu’on mesure c’est sa température,
et elle est de 2.725 K, c’est très précis.
Et d’une direction à l’autre, elle varie
de moins d’un millième de Kelvin. Et il
a fallu des appareils et des méthodes très
sophistiquées pour arriver à distinguer
ces variations minuscules qu’on représente
ici en couleur.]
Une température de rayonnement à ce point
identique dans toutes les directions, ça
semble indiquer qu’il y a 300 000 ans, quand
ce rayonnement a été émis, l’Univers
était déjà extrêmement homogène. Et ça,
en fait c’est un peu bizarre.
Généralement, quand on a une température
homogène par exemple, c’est qu’elle a
eu le temps et la possibilité de s’homogénéiser.
Pensez à la température dans une pièce
qui est initialement froide d’un côté
et chaude de l’autre.
[PIECE Il faut du temps pour que l’homogénéisation
de température se produise. Et puis surtout
il faut qu’il y ait une possibilité d’échanges
thermiques. Si vous isolez les deux parties,
pas de transfert de chaleur et donc pas d’homogénéisation.]
Et ce qui est bizarre avec l’homogénéité
du rayonnement fossile, c’est que ce rayonnement
nous provient de différentes régions. Or
d’après le modèle du Big-Bang, c’est
régions n’ont jamais pu être en contact
dans le passé. Alors comment elles pourraient
s’être homogénéisées ?
Ça peut vous paraitre étrange qu’on dise
que certaines régions de l’Univers n’ont
jamais été en contact les unes avec les
autres, mais on va éclairer un peu ce que
ça veut dire. Pour ça, parlons de la notion
d’Univers observable.
Je vous ai dit qu’on ne savait pas a priori
si l’Univers était fini ou infini, mais
ce qui est sûr c’est qu’à l’heure
actuelle, nous, on n’a accès qu’à une
partie de l’Univers, ce qu’on appelle
notre Univers observable.
[UNIVERS OBSERVABLE Comme il ne s’est écoulé
que 13.8 milliards d’années depuis le Big-Bang,
on ne peut observer que des objets dont la
lumière a eu le temps de nous parvenir. Il
existe dans l’Univers des objets, comme
des galaxies, qu’on ne peut pas voir, car
leur lumière n’a pas encore eu le temps
d’arriver jusqu’à nous.
Et la taille de l’Univers observable dépend
évidemment du temps qu’il s’est écoulé
depuis le Big-Bang. Il y a 10 milliards d’années,
l’Univers observable était plus petit que
ce qu’il n’est aujourd’hui.
Si on avait été là, il y a 10 milliards
d’années, avec le matériel nécessaire,
on n’aurait pu observer que les objets situé
à au maximum 3.8 milliards d’années lumières.
Et ça veut dire que si ensuite, pendant 10
milliards d’années, on était restés là,
à observer l’Univers, on aurait vu peu
à peu apparaitre de plus en plus de galaxies,
au fur et à mesure que leur lumière nous
parvenait, et que notre région d’univers
observable grossissait.]
Et en faisant ça, on se serait rendu compte
que les galaxies qui nous apparaissaient au
fur et à mesure n’étaient pas différentes
des autres qu’on connaissait déjà. Et
c’est là que se trouve le paradoxe.
Au moment où de nouvelles galaxies nous apparaissent,
c’est le tout premier contact entre leur
zone d’Univers et la nôtre. Et par contact,
j’entends le fait d’échanger des photons.
C’est le minimum si on veut s’homogénéiser
par exemple en échangeant du rayonnement
électromagnétique.
Et donc malgré l’absence de tout contact
préalable, ces galaxies semblent venir d’une
zone d’Univers totalement semblable à la
nôtre. Comment expliquer cela, comment se
fait-il que des régions puissent être à
ce point semblables, sans s’être jamais
vues, et donc sans avoir pu s’homogénéiser.
Pourquoi l’Univers est-il si homogène,
alors qu’il ne devrait pas ?
Bien, nous voilà donc au total avec deux
problèmes du modèle classique du Big-Bang
: pourquoi l’Univers est-il si plat, et
pourquoi est-il si homogène ? Eh bien l’inflation
cosmique, c’est une théorie qui prétend
résoudre à la fois l’un et l’autre de
ces problèmes. Alors voyons comment ça fonctionne.
[jingle]
Regardons la question de l’homogénéité
de l’Univers. On a vu que ce qui pose problème,
c’est la similarité apparente de régions
qui pourtant, d’après le modèle du Big
Bang, n’ont jamais été en contact par
le passé. Et si elles n’ont jamais pu être
en contact, c’est notamment parce que plus
on remonte dans le passé, plus l’expansion
était forte.
Tout à l’heure je vous ai représenté
l’évolution de notre zone d’Univers observable,
mais sans montrer l’impact du mouvement
d’éloignement des galaxies. Alors refaisons
ça un peu mieux.
[EXPANSION Prenons une galaxie située à
10 milliards d’années lumières de nous.
C’est-à-dire qu’aujourd’hui on voit
cette galaxie, et que la lumière qui nous
parvient d’elle a été émise il y a 10
milliards d’années. Elle est donc dans
notre zone observable et réciproquement.
Maintenant remontons dans le passé. Pour
faire ça on va utiliser la courbe d’expansion
de l’Univers. Si on remonte dans le passé,
certes cette galaxie était plus proche de
nous, mais notre bulle d’Univers observable
était aussi plus petite, donc à un moment
donné dans le passé, nous n’étions pas
encore en contact.
Par exemple il y a 12 milliards d’années,
la distance entre nous et elle n’était
que de 2 milliards d’années lumières,
mais il s’était écoulé moins de 2 milliards
d’années depuis le Big-Bang ! Donc à l’époque
on ne le voyait pas encore.
Alors on pourrait se dire, oui mais si on
remonte au tout tout début. Là très proche
du Big-Bang, toutes les régions de l’Univers
étaient proches les unes des autres, non
?]
Eh bien non, même si on remonte aux premiers
instants il n’y a pas de contact possible
entre ces deux régions de l’Univers. Et
la raison c’est que plus on remonte dans
le passé, plus l’expansion était forte.
[COURBE On voit que la pente était plus raide
au début, et si on zoomait on verrait quelque
chose de ce genre : l’expansion de l’Univers
a commencé très fort, éloignant immédiatement
toutes les zones d’Univers les unes des
autre sans qu’elles aient le temps de se
voir.
Et c’est seulement parce que l’expansion
se ralentit que deux zones d’Univers finissent
un jour par pouvoir établir un premier contact,
en se trouvant pour la première fois dans
la zone observable l’une de l’autre.
En conclusion, on ne peut pas expliquer que
l’Univers nous apparaisse si homogène aujourd’hui,
et c’est à cause de de la forme de l’expansion
qu’on voit ici.
Pour résoudre ce problème, il faudrait par
exemple changer l’allure de la courbe au
tout début. Plutôt que d’avoir une expansion
qui démarre à fond, il faudrait par exemple
commencer doucement pour que tout s’homogénéise
bien, puis une fois que c’est fait avoir
ensuite une période de forte expansion.
On voudrait une courbe plutôt de ce genre,
avec ici une période très courte de très
forte dilatation, et c’est ça qu’on appelle
l’inflation. Si on avait ça, ça pourrait
expliquer que l’Univers soit si homogène
aujourd’hui.]
Et outre la question de l’homogénéité,
une période d’inflation de ce genre résoudrait
aussi la question de l’Univers plat. Je
vous passe les détails mathématiques, mais
en gros une période d’inflation violente
aurait provoqué un applatissement monstrueux
du rayon de courbure de l’Univers, et c’est
ça qui expliquerait que l’Univers soit
si plat aujourd’hui.
Bien ça semble donc parfait cette solution,
mais comment on fait pour obtenir dans nos
modèles une période d’inflation de ce
type ?
[COURBE Vous voyez la courbe : on a besoin
d’une période d’accélération très
forte de l’expansion ici, mais qui cesse
pour ensuite laisser place à la courbe normale.
Or on connait un moyen d’avoir une expansion
accélérée : c’est exactement ce qu’il
se passe avec la fameuse énergie sombre.
Vous savez, l’expansion accélérée qu’on
peut observer aujourd’hui, et qui va se
poursuivre, elle est provoquée par une très
faible densité d’énergie sombre. Ca va
prendre des milliards d’années avant de
se voir, mais on est en fait dans une croissance
exponentielle. On est juste au tout début
de l’exponentielle.
Et donc ce dont on aurait besoin pour avoir
la forme de la courbe qu’on veut au début,
c’est d’une sorte d’énergie sombre
énorme, mais très temporaire, et qui s’éteigne
rapidement au bout d’un court moment.
On peut être plus précis que ça dans la
description de ce qu’on veut exactement.
On sait que pour expliquer l’homogénéité
de l’ensemble de l’Univers observable,
la période d’inflation devrait provoquer
une croissance d’un facteur 10 puissance
27 en un temps très court, environ 10-33
secondes.
Donc oui on veut un truc très très court
et très très pentu ici, et ce qu’il faut
c’est justifier d’où viendrait cette
sorte d’énergie sombre temporaire.]
Et c’est ce que propose le modèle de l’inflation.
Ce modèle postule qu’il existe un champ
quantique, on le surnomme l’inflaton, dont
l’énergie aurait été responsable de l’inflation
primordiale.
On ne connait pas la nature exacte de cet
hypothétique inflaton, et il existe de nombreux
modèles qui tentent d’imaginer ce qu’il
pourrait être et comment il évoluerait pour
provoquer la bonne inflation, puis s’éteindre
ensuite.
Le souci, c’est que si on n’a pas de conditions
plus strictes c’est un peu open bar : il
y a plein de modèles différents qui pourraient
faire l’affaire. Alors comment discriminer
et trouver le bon ? Et même, comment avoir
une preuve expérimentale que ce scénario
d’inflation est le bon ?
Eh bien on peut le faire grâce aux fluctuations
quantiques de ce champ. En effet ces fluctuations
qui existaient à l’époque de l’inflation
auraient été à l’origine des fluctuations
du rayonnement fossile, vous vous souvenez,
toutes ces très légères inhomogénéités
de température qu’on voit ici.
Et en analysant les fluctuations du rayonnement
fossile, on peut mettre des contraintes sur
les modèles d’inflation ayant une chance
de coller à la réalité. Voyons comment
ça se passe.
[PARAMETRES Il y a essentiellement deux paramètres
à surveiller, qu’on note respectivement
n_s et r. Le jeu est donc le suivant : si
vous proposez un modèle d’inflation, vous
devez calculer les valeurs théoriques de
n_s et de r qui sont associées à votre modèle.
Et ensuite vous regardez dans les fluctuations
du rayonnement fossile si ces valeurs ont
une chance de coller à la réalité. D’après
les derniers résultats issus du satellite
Planck, la valeur de n_s est de 0.9665 +-
0.0038, vous voyez que c’est assez précis.
Par contre la quantité notée r, on n’arrive
pas à en estimer une valeur. On sait jusque
qu’elle ne peut pas être plus grande que
0.1, mais on n’en sait pas plus. En particulier,
on ne peut pas, avec les données dont on
dispose, affirmer avec certitude que r existe,
qu’il est différent de zéro.]
Alors pourquoi je vous raconte ça sans vraiment
vous expliquer ce que veut dire ce paramètre
: parce que tous les modèle d’inflation
prédisent forcément une valeur de r qui
soit strictement positive. Donc tant qu’on
n’arrive pas à mesurer r et montrer expérimentalement
qu’il est bien différent de zéro, on peut
douter de la validité de toute cette approche.
Il y a quelques années, une collaboration
expérimentale appelée BICEP2 avait annoncé
en grande pompe avoir mesuré enfin une valeur
strictement positive pour r, ce qui aurait
constitué une preuve très forte de l’idée
d’inflation cosmique.
Et alors ils avaient fait la totale en communication,
et notamment débarquer à l’improviste
avec du champagne chez Andrei Linde, un des
théoriciens pionniers de l’inflation.
Tout ce petit monde se voyait déjà avec
le prix Nobel, sauf que la découverte a fait
pschitt. Il s’est avéré que leurs mesures
étaient entachées de bruit, et que finalement
rien ne prouvait que r soit bien strictement
positif.
A ce jour, on n’a donc pas de mesures expérimentale
qui corroborerait de façon indiscutable le
modèle de l’inflation, et permettrait de
mettre des contraintes plus fortes pour comprendre
sa nature et son origine.
Mais l’idée semble tellement simple et
séduisante, et elle permettrait comme on
l’a vu d’expliquer à la fois la platitude
et l’homogénéité de l’Univers. L’inflation
fait donc partie du paradigme actuel en cosmologie,
même si ces questions restent comme toujours
ouvertes.
Avant de conclure, un dernier élément : on
a vu que les éventuelles fluctuations quantiques
de l’inflaton pourraient avoir servi de
point de départ aux fluctuations qu’on
observe dans le rayonnement cosmologique.
Comme des perturbations initiales qui auraient
été amplifiées par l’expansion de l’Univers.
Eh bien ces perturbations pourraient aussi
expliquer la façon de se répartissent les
galaxies, et donc la structure à grande échelle
de l’Univers. Mais ça, ce sera pour un
prochain épisode.
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo, si ce contenu
vous a plu, n’hésitez pas à vous abonner,
pour ne rien rater des prochains épisodes.
Avec la déferlante des vidéos Shorts sur
Youtube, ça devient de plus en plus difficile
pour moi de faire émerger mes nouveaux épisodes,
même pour les abonnés. Donc n’hésitez
pas à mettre la cloche. Et j’espère avec
tout ça on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo. A bientôt.